Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years.
What is one thing that they would carry
with them?
The Quran. Why? Because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets. Brothers and sisters, imagine
you have a app, the Qurani app, which
not only shows you how much rewards you
get, but reminds you to read the Quran.
Gives you reminders. Download the Qurani
app now and let it testify for you on
Yawm al-Qiyamah that you read it
wherever was. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers and
sisters and dear friends. So, it looks
like Bahrain has been hit by the Iranian
missiles
in the oil refinery and some and some
residential buildings. And subhanallah,
brothers and sisters, Bahrain is a very,
very small country compared to Iran.
And you can see, if I'm not mistaken,
they are housing embassies. And this
comes after the Iranian president, if
I'm not mistaken, apologized for hitting
the neighboring countries. I don't know
what they mean by that because it's
quite bizarre because they did it on
purpose. So, what does that mean? Is
there a
conflict happening between the military
and the officials there? Because are you
guys not in sync or what's going on?
What are you apologizing for? It seems
strategic. So, subhanallah, here are
some footages that you can see of the
oil fields being being hit, some
residential areas. And if I'm not
mistaken, there is a footage of rocket
being fired from Bahrain to Iran as
well, which I do not know and I haven't
seen anywhere where it's been officially
announced that Bahrain sent that rocket.
But it's or whatever it's for that
matter towards Iran. You can see things
are escalating subhanallah because even
today, for example, what we know is that
Dubai airport got hit
with a drone, if I'm not mistaken.
So, you can see very clearly Iran is
strategically targeting the UAE
countries Subhan Allah specifically and
we've even had news which you can see
footage of Subhan Allah of
places in Saudi Arabia Arabia being hit.
So Iran is saying basically anyone
through these countries in these
countries that are hitting us talking on
behalf of America or Israel we will
target them. So Subhan Allah you can see
it's
very very crazy what's going on. There's
more than 14, 15, 16 countries involved.
Here's a video Subhan Allah of
apparently a US missile launched from
Bahrain towards Iran.
So yeah, there you go Subhan Allah. I
don't know how Bahrain with a very small
country like this and I'll be honest
with you I don't know I don't know
what's going through their minds because
at the end of the day
do they see as Iran as a threat? That's
why they're allying with the US. We do
not know Subhan Allah. But again, Subhan
Allah Allah Subhan Allah Ta'ala um tells
us Subhan Allah if you kill one soul it
is it is if you kill the whole of
humanity. And right now the amount of
death toll that's taking place it just
reminds me of the eye in the Quran where
Allah Subhan Allah Ta'ala tells the
angels when they say oh Allah they're
going to cause bloodshed and Allah
Subhan Allah Ta'ala says I know that
which you do not know. And Subhan Allah
you ask that question be like
sometimes what's the purpose of all of
this? But Allah Subhan Allah Ta'ala is
the all wise, the all knowing. And Allah
Subhan Allah Ta'ala has his plan and his
plan is the best of plans brothers and
sisters. And Subhan Allah innocent
people innocent Iranian girls and that
dozens, hundred more, hundred and fifty
plus
being massacred by American Israel bombs
on purpose Subhan Allah. Not only are
they raping little girls in those Peter
Islands, American little girls, now they
are trying to
give the freedom to Iranian girls by
massacring them. Subhanallah. Brothers
and sisters, as the updates come, I will
be doing videos to show you guys to tell
you guys what's exactly going on. But
right now, Bahrain has been attacked.
There's a alleged rocket being fired
from Bahrain to Iran, and the situation
is escalating. That's all I have to say,
inshallah, brothers and sisters. Keeping
you guys updated is very, very important
for us to geopolitically understand what
is going on. I urge you guys to
subscribe to the Political Alchemy
channel, Subhanallah,
where Subhanallah
the brother deals with it in detail,
inshallah, of what's exactly going on.
Till next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.